[Musique]
directement en janvier début d'une
journée marathon à l'antenne de paris du
département de la réunion depuis cinq
ans marié référente du pôle social
organise pour la fête des mères en
événements solidaires pour les malades
réunionnais et leurs accompagnants
choisiront d'hébergement ont réuni tous
les accompagnants mais depuis deux ans
vu le contexte sanitaire
c'est un peu plus compliqué donc on
livre pas dans les chambres
là où c'est possible vous a pas d'argent
si on pourra pas gérer puisque il ya
beaucoup dans y'a que des enfants et des
grosses pathologies le traiteur à venir
déposer d'accueil ils vont je sais pas
ce qu'ils vont faire avec
il voyait un temps tout cas avant de
remettre aux accompagnants malade on
essaie de faire du mieux qu'on peut mais
c'est vrai que c'est de ces deux années
ça peut compliquer compliqué mais jamais
impossible pour marie elle aussi vit une
fête des mères toute particulière entre
appels vidéo joue avec ses enfants et
maintient un peu effective de son en
raison des familles qui sera car depuis
deux ans trois ans qu'ils n'ont pas dit
leurs amis des fois leurs enfants même
des fois je pense quand même là on la
porte un peu de soleil comme on dit le
leurs plats et puis et puis je pense
qu'on l'antre par ses gestes à mlle
qu'on est quand même un recruteur et
fort noble qu on est quand même là qu'on
fait au niveau de l'antenne on est là
pour les soutenir dans les cas
difficiles les accompagner tout au long
de leur parcours de soin j'ai eu 2
enfants qui m'attendent mais voilà je
pense que et comprennent haye qui lui
comme ma fille me disait dernière fois
elle respecte mon engagement donc voilà
si ça me fait plaisir d'aider de donner
un peu de soleil à ces familles là bon
elle acquiesce c'est c'la cadeau de fête
des mères à leur façon qu en fait
en effet avant d'être matériel
l'engagement de marie et humains pour se
rendre accessible à tous
l'antenne de paris communique
régulièrement pour valoriser l'existence
de ces actions hors du commun
le matériel qu'on décrit c'est quelque
chose d'important mais l'accompagnement
moral c'est aussi une grande partie de
notre dispositif et c'est l'occasion là
le temps d'évoquer le fait pour que le
département mène une action récurrentes
notamment dans le cadre de la fête des
mères demain nous allons organiser une
action de distribution pour leur
apporter un peu de chaleur humaine
justement garder ce lien avec leur
culture et avec la réunion ce sera une
distribution de repas pays fait je
voulais souligner ça parce que on parle
beaucoup de l'aspect matériel mais
l'aspect psychologique surtout pour des
personnes qui doivent rester pendant
très longtemps pour suivre des soins sur
la métropole c'est une action qui est
importante
150 réunionnais sont prises en charge en
ile de france pour affronter les soins
liés à la maladie de leur proche
ces petites attentions pays c'est du
réconfort pour chacun cochet qui avait
livre de cuisine de la réunion des
livres d'histoire il y avait aussi et
objets en tamara etc
de quoi faire plaisir en gouttes pour la
tournée marathon à travers les quinze
lieux d'hébergement d'île de france qui
accueille les réunionnais ne faudrait
pas trop d'erreurs à la croisée
peut-être art en revanche fonction de la
circulation et après vente
après voile et armand trousseau on va
aller enfin on fait des monts ce qu'ils
ont dans des maisons individuelles en
dernier en plus des cadeaux tant attendu
chaque membre de la famille a pu choisir
son menu ressources en personnaliser la
qualité le côté madame et caler votre
corps il était de son côté là c'est
longtemps qu'elle est à marie connaît
très bien les pathologies qui touchent
ces malades pour préserver leur état de
santé
elle veille au grain comme cet
avoir une greffe dans quelques scènes
pratiquement pas dans fais très
attention à qui on dit le rejet par
rapport aux tisanes calibre même plus
dur
donc on ne part pas pour tous les
malades
ça fait chaud c'est super gentil avec
plaisir la part du département au
courage
bonjour
alors voilà les pour un hymne à moriat
commune gld accord verbal à son ipad
ceci voilà métier nous merci merci pour
tous affirme beaucoup surtout jour de sa
fête des mères c'est bien j'ai vu ta
matière à manger si pour certains la
distribution a pu se faire en main
propre ce n'est pas le cas de tout le
monde
mais la complicité qui existe entre les
malades et marie ne seront pas pour
autant de rien mais content que les
oiseaux par semaine mais un seul
prochain une journée vivent en émotions
rozier rouge où une dizaine de malades
réunionnais sont logés l'impatience
règne alors la distribution commence sur
le parking
des saignements comme escompté les
gentils l'air très beau cadeau mais les
employés en famille la réunion mais
c'est normal mais comme leur état de
santé le permet ces réunionnais vont
avant la chance de partager un petit
moment ensemble autour de ses souvenirs
du pays
un moment précieux de convivialité
franchement je suis trop heureux de
pouvoir le déjeuner pays
les cadeaux pour les mamans l'événement
fête ses 5 ans aujourd'hui elle n'est
pas près de s'arrêter
tout aussi souriante ne soit pas
[Musique]